hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend
uh one of the best podcasts that we've
ever made joined by Sonoma Obsession how
are you Sona good this is you know the
best podcast I've ever been in yeah yeah
yeah we've won several prestigious
Awards you know have we I think so have
we we have right yeah yeah okay cool
yeah I think it's important to know
that's good yeah congrats I don't know I
haven't seen the actual statues I
haven't either I think it was a prank
and uh also joined uh by Matt Gourley
how are you man I'm good how are you I'm
very well thank you
what is that why do I not look well well
usually by now you've insulted me so I
don't insult you a lot that's a bit you
know that I'm a really good guy to you
and are off mic time
all the times I've taken you out fishing
what off my time Dad
and the cats
yeah I'm feeling good and uh you know I
want to bring up something Sona sent me
this terrifying video the other day
absolutely terrifying of the moment that
her life changed for the worst oh
she sent me a video and I guess your
your twins uh Mikey and Charlie they're
in side by side cribs and you have
always put them to bed at night and then
you wake up in the morning and they're
right there and side by side cribs and
you woke up
one morning and they were both in the
same crib
and you went and you checked the night
camera yeah and you sent me this video
and it's Charlie
and you can see it's it's it's when uh
in like a Planet of the Apes movie where
the ape learns how to make fire yeah or
the ape learns how to log on computer
yeah 2001. you can see this moment where
Charlie's probably as he has for months
now he's kind of struggling and he's
kind of struggling and then he kind of
he's almost there and then he gets up
he's pulling himself up and he gets kind
of to the top and then you see he has
this look in his eye and he just Dives
on his brother and you hear
both start shrieking
and pounding each other and you realize
your life is over it's over was Mikey
asleep no Mikey was awake he was like
basically cheering his brother on yeah
then when Charlie did it Mikey's like oh
we can do this so now they're both
climbing not just into each other's
cribs they're just climbing out of their
cribs how do they get out the other side
without falling they do fall they don't
care they're just looking for Freedom
then by the end of the night it's much
later on you see them mixing various
powders to create TNT you can see that
they figured out the road just like we
gotta have some sulfur
yeah and they're they're figuring out no
that's too much this is just the right
amount and by the end they're putting it
into a brass cylinder yeah and they fire
off a Howitzer
no but I mean they're you're screwed
they're evolving they're evolving very
quickly I know I know I'm screwed and
now they like in the morning they'll
just jump out of their crib they oh no
to open the doors they'll like run into
our hear the car start
you're lying in bed thinking well
they're probably gonna watch cartoons
into reverse peels out your credit
card's missing oh no it's only a matter
of time it's awful I don't know what to
do people like you could put a canopy
over the crib but then I just feel like
they're in a cage don't fight it don't
fight it no I'm just or maybe you're on
to something cage them
yeah feral with hellofresh you get Farm
Fresh yeah free portions ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep that's huge I need
pre-portioned I know me too because my
portions are out of control yeah I get
too much of something and then it just
goes bad and starts rotting yeah well
you should learn to use refrigerator
anyway skip trips to the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and get this affordable
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit exclamation point now Sona
you've used hello fresh I have used
hello fresh you've cooked up some nice
meals for attack that's your husband yes
I have and you know what I like about it
is that it does come all in one one box
it's very it's stuff I would never
normally cook on my own and it have
everything you could possibly need in
you know when you're making a recipe and
it's like I'm gonna make clams Alfredo
yeah and you've got everything and then
you get to the very end I don't have the
clams that's the worst well that doesn't
happen with hellofresh I am Alfredo I
know go to hellofresh.com teamcoco16 use
code team coco16 for 16 free meals plus
free shipping that's hellofresh.com team
coco16. America's number one meal kit no
you know it's funny because we have uh
we have dogs and cats well we have one
dog that's just hyper and and he likes
it we've learned a long time ago he
would rather at night sleep in a crate
he just kind of prefers it so we'd put
him in this crate and he's who you're
talking about yeah okay no my dog okay
oh right yeah so we uh we put in this
crate and then he figured out recently
because he wakes up at five and he wants
to he wants to party down and it is a
really complicated system of like a
latch that's very complicated I have
trouble working it it's and I'm always
like I think I okay I there I think I've
unlocked it correctly now I've locked it
correctly
he figured out recently
how to unlock the cage and so at five in
the morning
he'll pound on the door with his head
and then push the door open and come in
and he's like what are we doing wow
what's the plan it's crazy he waits till
five yeah it's always five or five
thirty and um I'm saying now we have to
weld it shut every night
because I think if we we thought about
using like garbage ties but I think he
would you just see pause untying them
yeah and then he'd probably know where
he could return them or recycle them if
people want to escape they're just gonna
Escape I mean we had a hamster that
escaped for like two weeks and it was
somewhere in our house and we couldn't
find him for two weeks did you he was he
dead when you did no we found him he was
just living his life outside of his cage
wait a minute how did he live all that
time he was eating just random that
he would find did you notice that he had
his own uh profile on your television
Netflix account he had his own Netflix
account and it just it had a little
emoji of a hamster I've mentioned this
on the part yeah he's watching a lot of
True Crime who's watching all this who's
watching these romances these who's
watching he's just human romance he's
yeah he's watching human romance he says
who's watching all these bridgertons all
the 50 Shades movie and all the 50
Shades moves and your hamsters just up
drinking your liquor
watch holy yeah
he put beads in her ass
oh Minnie would never what are you
talking about it's a highly erotic scene
for hamsters in fact oh God some people
think a hamster can go up there it's
quite pleasurable come on I'm going to
tell you a true story
I gotta tell you a true story his Eiffel
Tower what the yeah you've said
more you've described more hideous
sexual positions than anyone in the
History Podcast okay oh it's the it's
the pirate The Angry Pirate yeah okay
listen sorry we can't I have to get this
who did that I have to get this out
really quickly which is uh because we
brought up I I brought up a hamster
maybe as a
um sexual uh deviance act an act of
sexual demons anyway
okay you know there was that rumor about
Richard Gere yeah sure from years and
years ago that Richard Gere enjoyed
having a hamster uh placed uh in his
bottom oh it's a gerbil yeah it was a
gerbil is there a big difference
I'm telling you they feel the same to me
[Music]
but anyway there was this rumor that you
know that that okay Richard Gere had
done that and then Flash Forward to its
1993 I think and I'm doing my late night
show and it's it's those early days when
it was really kooky and
uh it's always off the rails every night
and we might get canceled any second and
the guest that night was Mickey Rooney
who was as we all know the biggest movie
star in 1940 and now at this point he's
like 85 years old and he's pretty kooky
and out there and he's come on and he's
Mickey Rooney and he's telling stories
about 1940 I was the biggest star in the
world and he's talking he's telling all
these old show business anecdotes and
he's there and then at one point he
starts talking about a movie he had just
seen I forget which one it was if it was
Chicago or something and he went and it
has that actor in it what's his name he
was in and we're trying to figure out
Andy and I are there and this is actual
footage exists of this somewhere but
Andy and I are trying to help him figure
out what the who the actor is anyway it
was it was his actor and we were kind of
honing in on who it might be but we
hadn't said yet and we went really what
was it was it and all of a sudden Mickey
Rooney says ah yes there was talk of
gerbils
and the whole crowd gasped
and I like put my head on the desk and
Andy Richter loses it
there was talk of gerbils and I swear to
God every now and then I wake up in the
middle of the night and I just think
there was chalk of gerbils
he says it in such a crazy like they say
the Headless Horseman was never found
again
but he's talking about gerbils going up
Richard Gere's ass who is that actor who
was he I don't know I don't know who it
was I'm trying to think Mr Rooney wait a
minute there was talk of gerbils guess
what this is gonna be the new katakai oh
that's right you want people to yell at
you on the street when I walk around
anywhere in the world in the world I
mean this happened to me in in Thailand
recently people yell katakai well guess
what we're switching it up yes there was
talk of gerbils
you've heard it here
katakai is no longer active you get no
benefits from that yeah only there was
talk of gerbils
sure let's move on to a very esteemed
guest
s so much better
my guest today is an academy
award-winning actor so excited there was
chalk of gerbils I love how we drag
everyone down into the muffiness